In the U.S., President Donald Trump declared "a national emergency"...
...after the House joined the Senate...
...in passing a spending bill to prevent a government shutdown.
In India, Prime Minister Narendra Modi has placed blame on Pakistan...
...for the death of 41 citizens after a suicide bombing in Indian-controlled Kashmir.
In China, President Xi Jinping met with US trade delegation members in Beijing...
...in an attempt to discuss a trade deal between the U.S. and China.
In Paris, the Vatican's envoy to France, Archbishop Luigi Ventura,...
...is under investigation after being accused of molesting an employee of Paris City Hall.
Finally from Madrid, Spain's Prime Minister Pedro Sanchez...
...has called a general election for April 28th,...
...after his minority government's budget proposal was rejected by lawmakers.